michel guérard ben vous nous avez fait
des provisions
qu'est ce que vous nous proposez avec
tout ça la table est pleine eh bien oui
mais oui oui oui
et bien c'est pour faire un plat
principal ah bah oui oh moi à nous faire
une entrée c'est un plat principal ça
c'est ce sont des spaghettis gespeg et
hier je sais pas quoi bien manger puis
voilà alors c'est un j'ai appelé ça le
petit ragoût de spaghettis aux légumes
aux normes et d'inversion amusante wii 2
pour faire une spaghetti partie par
exemple coloré il faut que ce soit
coloré parce que les pattes en elles
mêmes sont un peu les allumer d'agents
attendait là spaghetti partie avant qu
est-ce qu on oui et bien vendre donc
puisque le sait le soir alors avant si
vous voulez on pourra manger par exemple
déguster une soupe de velouté de
grenouilles au cresson oui
alors après le raid le train c'est donc
le nôtre ragots avaient passé avec tous
les légumes
et puis après et puis poursuivre le soir
faut quand même pas proche se charger
alors par exemple un gâteau diplomate
oui et puis on va boire quelque chose
alors si vous voulez on va on peut
rester sur un
on peut rester sur un vin blanc je pense
1,20 à 20 des landes qui s'appelle le
vin de tursan qui est très bon quand il
est plus jeune mais quand il prend un
peu d'âge il est également très bon
parce que il eu un peu de goût il change
a salué par un good i'm a alors c'est
vrai il est très différent voilà allez
on n'est pas venu là pour cause et non
non non on va travailler
alors donc qu'est-ce que je fais moi les
spaghettis ou alors parler il y a ça
tout ça c'est pour quatre personnes
bon il y à 200 g de spaghettis oui voilà
que nous allons donc cuir dans 2 litre
et demi d'eau à peu près avec 50 g de
sel alors assez ça nous va commencer par
ça mais si vous voulez on va reprendre
toute la recette à ses spaghettis
nous allons ajouter tous ces légumes
alors ces légumes c'est du maïs en boîte
tout simplement on en mettra une poignée
de dans à peu près pour qu'à perçage
pour pour 4 personnes toujours un une
poignée de petits concombres tournée
vous rappeler qu'on a déjà
on s'est déjà amusé à tourner pour bien
expliquer la chose
voilà les concombres voilà le concombre
tel qu'il ya la coupe en quatre et avant
et après c'est comme le couvent 4 et
puis après bien on lui donne cette forme
d'olive qui est un peu plus harmonieuse
que ce que ce morceau un peu trop brut
nous mettrons également des champignons
coupés en morceaux que nous ferons
sauter nous mettrons des petits pois
alors les petits pois voyez cela j'ai
acheté des petits pois surgelés qui sont
merveilleux parce que il n'y a pas de
faux se monte à acheter des petits pois
surgelés d'ailleurs à mon avis ils sont
alors là je pense qu'ils sont bien
meilleurs que tous les petits pois frais
parce qu'on tombe jamais au bon moment
pour les manger ils ont une poignée de
de choux fleurs que l'on ajouté dans
l'eau pour cuire que nous ferons
également sauter là il s'ancre eu un peu
de fond d'artichaut que nous couperont
en morceaux que nous ferons également
sauté et puis nous allons pour lier ses
spaghettis faire un beurre à un mélange
de beurre et de crème que nous allons
monter dans lequel nous mettrons des
petites lanières de maurice et chez que
je fais crampes et pour donner un parfum
de champignons et puis aussi également
un petit peu de d'estragon là au
vinaigre bien et puis voilà c'est tout
on la sent tout c'est vous les japonais
on va cuire on va commencer à salé no no
no zoo alors là je vous dis on va même
volé le pack offroad points soit bien 50
grave
voilà là je mets une petite poignée
surveillé qu'il soit pas trop cuit oui
oui oui al dente un surtout un alors
nous allons commencer par cuire les
petits choux fleurs voilà j'en mets
poignet pour 4 se mangera leur s il y en
a trop grâce à moi j'aurais cru j'aime
bien oui alors les spaghettis jouer mais
ils sont quand même un peu long je vais
les couper en 2 1 parce que tout le
monde n'aime pas c'est dommage
alors vous voulez vous leur pied non non
mais parce qu'il ya des objets il ya des
gens qui n'aiment pas ce sens vers les
filles côté dans les spaghettis ça vient
je crois de l'italien spago qui veut
dire ficelles je crois même si c'est pas
c'est joli ça peut ça peut être ça pour
être son histoire de pas y penser
voilà bonfoh 6 8 minutes selon lui alors
moi ah bon alors on peut un peu
montrer à nos amis comment tourner le
concombre on enlève les angles pour
donner donc cette forme d'olive
c'est joli et qui fait penser un petit
légume qui aurait été cueillis telle
qu'elle voit là alors maintenant nous
allons couper nos champignons coupés nos
fonds d'artichauts j'ai oublié de parler
de la tomate concassée à ça aussi ça le
moment nous allons l'ajouter au nous la
mettrons à la fin cette tomate concassée
c'est pour apporter également la couleur
tomates concassées vous savez ce que
c'est que la tomate concassée de marx et
une tomate fraîche que l'on trempe
quelques le second secondes dans l'eau
chaude
on l'appelle on enlève la peau elle
s'emballe un seul coup on sait dans la
presse alors après on coupe la tomate en
deux et puis on la presse est à dire qu
on fait partir l'autre végétation ainsi
que les pépins voilà par la pression de
de la main et puis c'est tout alors donc
voilà tout ce que nous allons couper en
cubes en morceaux alors les fonds
d'artichauts le petit cheval et couper
en quartiers comme ça oui
je
dès 8 ans et au patch regarde l'heure
des pintes
voilà bon ça on en a pas besoin
ils sont tout épluché vous avez tout
prévu oui les champignons pour c'est un
pelage extrêmement simple finalement
mais amusant vous savez quand on reçoit
des gens c'est amusant de l'ancien du
tout voilà pas tellement cher non se
porter c'est le plat de résistance
c'est le plat de résistance d'une soif
t'amusant les gros appétits nous
n'aurons pas les ennuis
non et puis alors selon évidemment les
gens courent c'est bon vous pouvez
toujours augmenter la quantité de la
quantité de spaghettis 1 et vous faites
toujours avec du mais c'est pas
interchanger pas de ma vie je vais m oh
non je fais ça vous savez qu'un jour je
savais plus quoi manger souvent je vous
arrivent oh oui c'est non mais c'est
vrai je savais plus quoi manger alors
qu'est-ce que je bon il y avait des
spaghetti qui traînait dans un coin je
me les suis fait cuire puis puis avait
plu j'ai vu d'autres légumes à côté puis
voilà c'est comme ça c'est pas plus
difficile que ça finalement il n'y a pas
de recette précise c'est simplement une
rumeur du moment
alors ça c'est ce qui coûte le plus cher
ce sont des mauries sécher que j'ai fait
tremper à l'eau pour les ramener pour
les réhydrater
alors c'est maury donc comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure vont aller dans le
beurre le mélange de beurre et de crème
d'accompagnement qui va lier l'ensemble
et qui donc amène pour quand même ça va
relever à mouiller un goût sympathique
voilà c'est la note brune au maillot
tricolore michel oui c'est très
attention c'est important quand le mer
rouge est important d'éclairer les
platines lorsque je pense que ce serait
triste si on ne tenait pas compte
justement de du plaisir qu'ont les yeux
quand ils découvrent un plat en fait
vous savez on mange avec le palais mais
au moins jeu égal
on mange d'abba la pluie que les yeux
oui le peuple on y lit plaisir je vous
dirais que le des fois les les oreilles
peuvent précéder le palais parce que
vous savez un l'odorat un rôti que vous
sortez du four qui crépite encore
allume l'appétit oui l'odorat ensuite
good or oui oui ensuite mais je vous dis
tout peut se passer en même temps vous
laisse ensuite c'est là dans les résines
tous les sens sans son sont tenues son
risque d'être bouleversée par un beau
plat enfin peut-être tient alors voilà
donc mes petites fleurs de chou-fleur
608 à le détester
non non non non je vais tout sûrs d'eux
dans là je vais cuir il me reste à
accueillir rapidement les concombres
concombre il faut à peu près dix minutes
de cuisson
je vais je ne sais même au blaireau y
sont peu importants en soit je jetterai
les les petits pois très rapidement
également au dernier moment
oui au dernier moment voilà je h très
grossièrement sont deux thomas dans mon
salon rigueur oui d'automates pour des
cas mal pour 4h c'est grossièrement
c'est ça voilà comme ça je vais de
l'étaler comme ça cette tomate jeu l'ami
cru dedans parce que j'aime bien ça oui
mais enfin les packs 8,1 le fait de la
plongée n'a fait que naquit permis à
face il permet d'enlever la peau de
l'appeler mais c'est tout il n'ya pas
y'a pas de cuisson à proprement parler
alors ça vous avez faire sauter alors ça
je vais faire sauter je vais amener ma
poil
je remettrai après là dessus je ferais
sautez donc ça très rapidement oui donc
dans le beurre et dans le lait dans
l'île et je vais dans cette casserole
mettre quelques cuillerées d'eau pour
monter le beurre qu'est ce que ça fait
de la en fait le lot permet aux une
liaison est une espèce de
d'homogénéisation qui se produit
d'émulsion oui entre le beurre lait
entre le beurre et lots qui fait qu
entre le beurre et l'eau qui fait que le
beurre se lit quand on le monte très
légèrement à chaud alors je vais mettre
les cadres à foix il ya 200 g de beurre
1 je vais mettre à peu près 4 4
cuillerées d'eau ce qui correspondait
cuiret bush qui correspond à 5 606
litres d'eau 1
voilà je vous le dis comme ça pour votre
gouverne alors je prends de l'audi si
vous prenez l'eau à bord oui oui on voit
chez très fin oui un peu plus fin que
vous ne l'avez fait un bon match devant
ça se mélange un peu plus intimement
dans le beurre je pensais qu'il fallait
qu'ils gardent leur parfum oui mais ça
va garder son parfum mais comme il y à
un liquide en fait ça va être devenir
une infusion annoncé quand il va pas y
avoir perdition de parfum
bon voilà alors maintenant le beurre oui
alors ça on va le mettre en valais c'est
on va faire tiédir ça dans quelques
instants et puis on montera tout
doucement le le beurre et qu'est ce que
vous mettez dans l'eau le petit pois je
levais et les jetées vraiment une
seconde voilà jusque là donc on peut
tout faire dans la même eau un sens sans
arrière-pensée maintenant ça les
souffleurs les petits voilà mesdames
nous nous compliquons pas se compliquer
l'existence simple
non parce que ce ses légumes qui sont là
vont être cités
je vais les ferrari mais pas les plats
les bois et ben oui vous voulez me
l'enlever le restant des petits pois les
mises là dedans et pendant ce temps je
vais faire sauter les légumes les
légumes soient là quelle proportion
ville et beurre ou mettez moi dire on a
dit et michel à peu près oui à peu près
vous voulez regoûter lait les pâtes
marseille je crois alors là je mets
d'abord mes champignons
et vous savez il ya des semoule
également plus ou moins durs l'an encore
une minute une minute d art y un oui
très bien violence allait un peu les
champignons comme ceux ci soient vrais
également vous les faites sauter combien
de temps des champignons jusqu'à ce
qu'ils soient colorés qu'ils aient pris
une jolie couleur marron clair tous ceux
qui aiment le qui aime bien le parfum du
temps peuvent rajouter en cours de
cuisson un peu de thym voilà donc c'est
peut-être dans l'autre sens c'est très
bien alors là le jeu mais je débarrasse
tous les légumes sautés séparément dans
ce récipient laert maintenant si vous
voulez vous avez goûté lait les pâtes
j'ai mis là bas une passoire que j'ai
trouvé mais il faut que vous l'égoutier
directement de ceux là bas rien et voilà
mais là oui on voyait non mais je vais
arrêter le haut mais quand même ça va
pas s'arrêter tout de suite
voilà donc ça va aller bon il répond
qu'il mettait une goutte d'eau dedans
pour que ça ne sèche pas oui
voilà deuxièmes légumes sautés
maintenant nous allons sauter les fonds
d'artichauts juste le fond les recouvre
michel nom comme ça non non non juste un
tout petit peu m'a fait voir vraiment
salaces être de trop non ça va c'est
très bien ça là je vais monter le beurre
après alors mart la sauce donc voyez
dans ce type de dollars à l'eau et le
serveur oui là je vais ajouter les
morceaux de beurre comme ça à part 1 200
g de beurre
oui 200 g de beurre pour quatre
personnes oui c'est ça oui alors il faut
que chaque fois monté comme ça à faible
température sur une plaque 12e cercle en
émulsion se produisent bien
[Musique]
elle y en a je vais retourner sont très
bons le l'artichaut de jeu cuit alors je
vais mettre entre deux voiliers mars et
ses petites miettes nos de spaghettis là
dedans pour qu'elle commence à imprégner
les pattes de leur parfum vous mettez
les mots rires oui voilà comme ça de dhr
et maureen l'engament henry dont
s'épanouira getty c'est ça le parfum va
s'épanouir dans le trophy là vous pouvez
enlever marque c'est bien saiem avec
brida d'audience très bien et même un
abattoir
il y en a parfois fait très bien le
beurre harraga bien non non non on en a
plus besoin maintenant c'est très bien
bon alors les petits pois les met
maintenant à côté du oui alors les
petits maïs on va pouvoir on va mettre
le maïs là dedans et les petits pois là
dedans maintenant oui vous pouvez y
aller oui voilà très bien j'en avais mis
points
les petits pois vous pouvez tout m c'est
une cuillère
vous voulez mettre tous les petits bois
[Musique]
voilà très bien alors vous voyez mart
que le mélange tout en continuant de
chauffer l'eau et de beurre épais si
vous voyez deviens tu veux en fait c'est
un peu le principe du beurre blanc s'il
roule ce fameux beurre blanc qui
accompagnent les poissons c'est quelque
chose comme ça alors on met le brière
était quelqu'un des ratures il est il
sort pas du beau jeu de rappeler il est
quand même assez ferme parce que s'il
était trop haut trop mou on n'arriverait
pas à faire la liaison
il est il est avant la pommade avant la
porte à dire que je les sorties à la
température de la cuisine avant et je
l'adopté en honneur y'a pas de problème
avec les projecteurs cda spéciale
est ce qu'il ya eu alors avec le fouet
et bien ma foi on fait on établit la
liaison c'est à dire le mélange on
arrive à amalgamer donc bien ensemble le
mélange d'eau et de beurre tout en
incorporant de l'air on a levé le pied
marc vous pouvez maintenant mettre le
les trois quarts des tomates là dedans
il ya de l'eau encore mais ça fait rien
marin ben oui il faut qu' il faut qu'il
reste de l'eau c'est bien mieux
il y en a presque pas d'ailleurs et
trois cadets thomas oui alors je vais
reprendre un peu de ce beurre parce que
j'en avais pris une certaine quantité
pour sauter je ne suis pas perçu est ce
que c'est un beurre spéciale samedi
albert plus ou moins humide besoins dont
jean marc et le canton fait ça avec du
beurre demi sel comme il en existe en
bretagne moi personnellement je préfère
d'abord meilleur à wilshere musée tout
tout doucement avec cette fourchette là
parce que là ça devient assez précieux
comme ça voilà sous le vent
[Musique]
le tout pendant combien de temps nos
savanes d'accès mélanger c'est bien ça
suffit alors je vais salle et mon beurre
la voilà un petit peu comme ça le poivre
également y ajouter un jus de citron
admis entier 1 2 million à demi citron
voilà et puis les deux cuillères de
crème qui sont dans la recette que vous
mettez dans un sol dans le beurre c'est
grâce si on met pas la crème a pas du
tout non en fait si vous voulez c'est
pour vous c'est me pour une ménagère
c'est mieux parce que ça empêche un peu
le beurre de 2,2 tournée de virer moi
suis ici sinon j'aurais mis que du pain
du beurre très bon comme ça alors nous
allons donc marthe maintenant mettre une
partie de ce beurre comme ça oui
tout y est avec nous en ce moment les
ans ici je le met là alors je lui alors
que comme j'ai fait voilà avec
maintenant une partie on va se mettre là
si vous voulez mari
on va aller là-bas
avec une partie des légumes jolie une
partie parce que comme je vous l ai dit
tout à l'heure nous allons consacrer une
autre partie pour la décoration autour
c'est pourquoi face jolis seins ses amis
dans votre plat il est très amusant
alors les souffles le maïs
voilà pourquoi je remets tout doucement
ça bravo très bien voilà tout commence à
se mélanger et bien ma femme était bien
maintenant nous allons tous vidés sur
l'art sur le plat oui comme ceux ci la
décoration
voilà vous y que c'est assez enfantin
finalement comme recette en disant ah
oui c'est pour le décor assez haut
reste un petit peu long à préparer
oui oui mais quand c'est presse est
prévu c'est à dire que vous pouvez
maintenant le résistant l'estonie vous
comprenez ça vous permet quand même de
devenir à table avec nos invités
quand même et ça on met rien là je suis
encore du vert
on peut tout de même trouver les
victoires c'est une vraie bonne idée
j'ai peur tout est très lequel le plat
bascule au mart
non mais écoutez vous étiez un équilibre
si elle voulait sauver la vie la
désobligeance chers amis je note ben moi
je vais surtout noté la recette pour la
recherche proche oui l'adami qui
viennent et laissait vraiment le plein
les traits sont sans problème pour les
alors donc le restant de du beurre y ait
quelques jours reviendront bientôt
dévoilé on fait un cordon tout autour
c'est ça mais en fait c'est pas une
obligation
en tout cas faut mettre toute cette
quantité de mélange crème et beurre un
après dans l'assiette chacun fait sa
petite salade sa petite cuisine c'est le
cas de dire eh bien voilà ce plat est
terminée dans sa simplicité
on peut dire dans sa facilité par un
milliard il voit bien agréa la familiale
est raisonnable à tous égards
[Musique]